um so i welcome to this talk called
secure coding back to basics um i had
the idea for this talk uh a few years
ago and i've kind of been wanting to do
it for some time
and the idea of the talk was to do a
talk that was um
kind of beginner friendly because we
have a lot of people kind of moving into
security uh that uh
and in a lot of other talks we talk
about like advanced exploits and stuff
like that but what about like the basics
but i also wanted to create a talk that
was uh valuable also for experienced
programmers so
i'm going to try to show you some
concepts that we can use in code that
you might or may not find valuable i
think they're really useful because i've
used them in projects
and
we'll see how that goes i i will show
some code in many of the slides the code
will be in various languages uh i know a
lot of people going to ndc is uh like
c-sharp programmers and stuff like that
but this will be like java and kotlin
and even typescript uh but uh i think it
will be very much translatable over to
for instance c sharp because i know
people who have done it
uh i'm alan i
work as a security researcher as at
cross point labs which is actually in
this building i recently started there i
write casual bug bounty hunter because i
there's longer longer breaks between
each time i do bug hunting these days
and i also build and maintain some open
source security tools and i'm an always
chapter leader in in norway actually to
say oslo because we now have a christian
son chapter as well which is great
um
first thing first complexity is the
enemy of security this has been said
many many times and it's really true
like the the more complex our code
becomes the harder it is to secure
uh and things tend to grow over time
right uh but but like if you we keep
adding stuff we keep adding stuff and
and making things more complex they
start out it's something simple we have
an idea for a program that we want to
build or a website or whatever and we
build it and and then we get new
features and we kind of add stuff and
especially if we're pressed on time we
never
have time to kind of rewrite stuff and
simplify stuff so things tend to get
more and more complex as we go
and this is of course a problem
the more complex stuff is as i said the
more the harder it is to secure and the
harder is to get things right
and when we don't get things right we
have bugs and vulnerabilities they are
also just bugs there's nothing special
about a security bug as opposed to
another bug they're just bugs
so when we write something that happens
to be insecure our code can do something
that it wasn't supposed to do
in under some certain circumstances
and
various security companies have
suggested that 50
of uh security vulnerabilities are
actually logical security bugs
and this part is quite interesting
because
a generic scanner can only find generic
bugs it can't find the logical security
bugs because the logical security bugs
are
based on the rules of the of the domain
we're in
so
if if we're writing a code for a certain
business function and that function has
to certain rules that there's no way a
scanner can know about those rules so we
will have problems that are related to
uh things that can be done in weird
order uh things that can be broken like
authorization bugs and all kinds of
stuff that can go wrong
i'm going to show you bug types in
order of personal preference some of you
might not agree with this
but i really like compile time errors
those are the best because i get them in
my face immediately so i know there's
something to fix
right there there hey you did something
wrong you're stupid fix it okay cool
i'll fix it
uh the next type of bugs that i i i'd
rather have them as compile-time bugs
but okay if they're caught by automated
tests
that's cool i i'll find them before i go
into production
great
or maybe i have some colleagues that
kind of looking at my code and say hey
what are you doing here okay that's fine
as well i'd rather have them found by
the automated tests but okay as long as
someone finds them that's fine
even manual tests
better than having things into
production
then of course a standard runtime bug
something that was supposed to work in a
certain way didn't uh
but wasn't necessarily vulnerability
which is the next thing
i don't want vulnerabilities in
productions
and i especially don't want
exploited vulnerabilities in production
and uh
i have to add this at the end like those
really annoying bugs that only occur
under certain circumstances and you
can't really find out what they are and
you spend days and weeks trying to
figure out exactly what's going on and
why this stupid message is ending up in
the log every thursday at 12 or
something uh but yeah um
the point of this is i want
things to move upwards like the more
things that i can have as compile-time
errors the happier i will be
um and
i've been in the security space for
quite a long time i
i wrote this blog post in 2006 and i was
thinking about like okay what's what's
going on why do we have all these
security issues
uh and people kept saying uh you have to
validate your inputs
and of course yeah i should validate my
inputs but then at some point i realized
well validating our inputs is not going
to stop sql injection or cross-site
scripting
because it's kind of a different problem
and it's kind of paradoxical that i'm
now going to talk a lot about input
validation for the next minute but i
still think input validation has a place
and is super important but it's not
necessarily what's going to stop sql
injection and cross-site scripting
but the reason why i'm bringing this up
is i wrote this blog post and then later
i wrote a series of blog posts that
caught the attention of some sweets
and these suites work for a company
called omegapoint
and they are really smart
and so they were working on an idea that
they were calling domain driven security
and
they read my blog post and say hey this
guy's thinking about some of the same
stuff as us we should talk to him and
and so um a guy called don byjunson
contacted me and said hey i i saw your
blog post this is interesting because
we're working on this idea over here and
i really like their idea
they their ideas were much better than
mine and they actually also uh they they
took uh some inspiration from the main
driven design hence the name domain
driven security and then they uh they
kind of built stuff around it and use
the concepts from the main driven design
and it also ended up in a book that they
wrote called a secure by design which i
highly recommend
um
so i mentioned domain driven design
for those of you who are not fluent in
the main drawing design i'm going to
just mention three
terms that are often used in the main
drum design we have a ubiquitous
language which is like a language that
we use within a
company or in a certain part of a
company where we have specific words
with a specific meaning that may not
mean anything to someone or may mean
something completely different to
someone outside
we have a bounded context this is kind
of a closed context where this thing is
valid and we can have many bounded
contexts
and then we have what we call an
anti-corruption layer
which is when we move things in and out
of the bounded context we want to make
sure that we don't break stuff and that
we interpret things in the right order
kind of like input validation
to show you an example
if we have
a quantity in in a web shop
uh for the website itself for the web
shop itself uh we if we're gonna buy
something it needs to be larger than
zero because we can't buy zero uh
computers we have to buy at least one
computer if you want to buy something
but probably we don't want something or
someone ordering like a huge amount of
stuff either so we we have some rules
around what what isn't what is a
quantity when we want to order something
so but however in in the returns
department a quantity might be negative
because we're getting something back
like there's someone returning something
so we now get in uh
a computer that someone didn't want so
they're returning it to us now a
quantity can suddenly be negative and so
we can see we have two bounded contexts
where the same
terminology or the same term means
different things and this is often a
cause of security problems because we
think we're talking about the same thing
but we're not and maybe it's possible on
the website to order minus two books and
then we have a problem
um
and uh
when i was talking to to uh don baionsen
and the others about this uh uh
don by johnson also held a talk where he
talked about like how what happens with
with data how can data be represented
and
i i created this this slide where we
have some data in the database
and then that data can be represented in
many different ways in our system so
this is a very simple system where we
have a database we have a server uh we
have some json going back and forth we
have some
query language that we can query the
database we're transferring it over to
some javascript running on the front
then which then uses some templating and
it's rendered into html
so the same entity
sitting in a database can be a an object
on the server it can be an object in
javascript or just a struct in
javascript
and it can be represented in many
different ways in html so for instance
if it's a user it could be a row in the
database but it could it could be the
icon up at the top that shows that you
are like your avatar it could be the
forum where you can edit your profile
those are all representation of the same
entity and the point here is
so many of the problems that we have
related to security
they happen when we move from one
representation to another
so when we go from server side into a
query language that's where sql
injection occurs when we go from
javascript into html that's where xss
occurs
and and when things are coming in from
the client side into the server side
that's where all kinds of authorization
errors and deserialization errors and
all that kind of stuff occurs
so this going back and forth between
different representations that's the
that's a big part of the problem
hence we need to talk about input
validation
but i don't think that input validation
necessarily is
only a security mechanism i actually
think it's more of
a thing that we should think about as a
data quality thing like we want to make
sure that this piece of data is valid
like does it make sense for for this
system to have this piece of data
uh can a username be
a thousand characters probably not
because we we have some ideas of of the
lengths of things and how things are
supposed to be structured
so the fact that it stops or limits many
types of attacks that's actually kind of
a side effect
though that side effect is important
so um
when we talk about input validation
there are many ways of doing the input
validation so we can think about format
so the syntax of of the input does this
look like a date or is it just garbage
but
if it's just a date well a date can be
any date it could be a thousand years
into the future or it could be year zero
so we probably want some semantics
so if this is a birth date
our users are probably not born in 1556
and they're probably not born in 2048
because
that doesn't make any sense they
probably weren't even born in 2022
because uh babies rarely use the
internet
so we need some kind of validation
uh sometimes we also uh want to check
the data with other data that we have so
we might want to look up stuff in a
database the words i'm using here syntax
semantics domain people use different
terms for this this can be confusing but
just remember that
some some things are just syntax some
things are
are the values somehow valid does do
they seem valid in this context and then
sometimes we can't just do simple
validation we have to go look them up
somewhere that's the important part
so we we talked about a birth date so we
could start just validating the syntax
with the regex okay so we have a year we
have a month and we have uh um
a day
but as mentioned we probably want to
check that it's kind of between some
sensible limits that we have if we want
to to check that this this value looks
valid
sorry
yeah the month could be 99 up here true
so that's also a problem uh like so so
it's a bit simplistic the the regis at
the top
but we want to start somewhere
next up a product id maybe the product
is just a number but we also want to
check that that product actually exists
before we allow it into an order for
instance so we can't order a product
that that we don't have
uh but then we move into the the harder
things to to validate like uh a comment
so okay so we could allow letters and
numbers and spaces and stuff like that
but then suddenly if this was stack
overflow and you wanted people to be
able to discuss programming then you
suddenly have to start allowing
characters that can be used for attacks
for instance a
sql injection or a cross-site scripting
another problem is encoding
in coding
things can be encoded in so many
different ways
so in javascript for instance the string
abc has a length of three
but this string which also looks like it
has three characters has a length of
four
because why not
the center character is a multi-byte
character so it consists of two
surrogate pairs and so javascript thinks
this has a length of four
we can also have weird stuff going on
like this so we have an a with an accent
equals an a with an accent and
javascript says no
okay
why is that well because one of them is
the letter
an accent and an a so it's a combining
character and the other one is the
actual letter a with an accent
so we can have an a with many accents
and then we have emojis
looks like one character has length 11.
okay
but this tells us something like it can
be hard in certain languages to
know the length of something if we want
to impose limits
so uh elm for instance they had the
exact same same issue because they kind
of compiled stuff into javascript and
they inherited all the weird length
stuff that you see here
so we have to normalize input somehow uh
and we can do that by
just deciding on a form uh so if we have
the a with the accent we could decide we
always want to split these two things
out so we want to have the letter with
an accent and then the a or we could say
well if it's an a with an accent we
always use the letter a so same thing
for xml like an empty tag could be
an opening and a closing tag just next
to each other or it could be like a
self-closing tag
but we have to decide if we want to do
validation and then emails and urls and
host names well you can have
international letters in
in host names for instance but there
you have to decide do you want to look
at this as puny code or do you actually
want to allow those characters in there
and you have to decide on this before
you start doing the syntax validation
and stuff like that
do i have to normalize the input
another principle here is don't try to
clean invalid inputs so if you know
something is bad don't try to fix it by
removing stuff
just say i don't want this as an
application just i i this is invalid
data i don't want it don't try to okay
we're gonna fix stuff i'm just gonna
remove some stuff because this is a very
simple example like okay we're gonna
remove all the script tags so we remove
it once and then we have a new script
type because like things are
concatenated and then you have a script
all over again so this is just a really
dumb and simple example but you can
imagine stuff like this happening if you
try to fix
fix the input to clean the input then
this might happen
so there are
good cleaners that can do this for for
html like dom purify
so if you want to do it or actually want
need to clean something because
you can't just reject everything then at
least use something that has been very
well tested but try to avoid it if you
can just reject the input and say i
don't want this
so we have a set of steps
we normalize the input we check the
length first and we check the length
first before we go into reg x's or stuff
like that because if we have a quite a
long string that
doesn't exactly match we might end up
with our redos if our regular expression
was poorly created
and other similar stuff so we check the
length before we go into the next things
so check the format we check the
semantics and then we use the value that
we
validated this is also something i've
seen so many times where people do
normalization and all kinds of checks
and then they end up using the value
they started out with which was not the
one that went through normalization et
cetera
and last but not least we check the
domain if that's necessary like so we
can go and look up the id in a database
or whatever it is
so
i now just talked about the input
validation what is this domain driven
security thing
this is a rather funny example or
depending on who you are
this was apple they were going to show
you your password hint but they
accidentally showed you your password
instead
so you had two fields the hint and the
password and they were accidentally
flipped in the code so you showed the
wrong thing
uh
and this can happen because we tend to
pick stupid types for stuff basically
so this is aina hust who works at
anacond
and he says did i mention i hate string
i hate string people who have the
decency to refrain from using object
will still gladly use string with
assumptions all over the place
we tend to use strings and and primitive
types a lot
and we don't necessarily mean
string because a string can be
zero bytes it can be two gigabytes is
that the string is that the string we
want
i don't know i found another blog post
called something isn't something else
and i really like this this picture so
we have this idea of something another
main concept
and then we kind of try to transfer that
concept into code and it doesn't really
match because we we're
taking a lot of shortcuts
uh and it mentions primitive obsession
down here so we tend to like just pick
some some primitive some strings and
stuff and just okay that works uh
but then we end up with something
that's called stringly typed code
we don't really use the type system we
just use strings string string string
public void register string email
address screen password string phone
number
are they all the same
really
if we look at like if we could like
imagine this as the total amount of
strings that we could have
so we have email addresses and we have
phone numbers and they don't overlap but
we said string spring string right
this is odd
why are we doing this because well it's
easy
but what if we did something like this
instead
email address password phone number we
had some classes we had some types then
we wouldn't accidentally flip the
password and phone number or something
like that because
the compiler would yell at us hey this
is not a this is not a phone number this
is a password
okay
we could even do something like this we
could package them together in a class
and actually have a proper encapsulation
of them
and not
pass a lot of strings okay
so
but if we look at the center one so we
we we have something called an email
address we have something called a phone
number
this is what is called in
a domain primitive so we we take a value
and we kind of wrap it in a class
and the point of this is
that class can enforce rules
so we take an implicit concept which was
a string and we now make it explicit so
we have an email address instead of a
string email address we now have a
proper email address or a phone number
so we can create a class and within that
class
if you if in the constructor we're going
to check that the string that we give it
is in fact a phone number or we might
throw an exception and say hey this is
not a phone number this is a password or
is this an email address it's not gonna
say that it's just gonna say invalid
phone number but you get the idea
we can have
the class itself enforce that you're
you're not inputting invalid data and
the point of this is whenever we have an
object of type phone number we know that
it contains valid data it a phone number
object will never contain an email
address because it it's you can't create
an object like that
so and we could also have like a a
method a static method so you could
check something if you don't didn't want
to to go right into throwing exceptions
and stuff like that
so so this is one way of doing it and
and of course
when people see this they often think
well okay so i'm just going to write all
these domain primitives and then they
kind of start accessing the value up
there because it's public final string
value
why is it public why is it a string why
is it available
well it's available because in this case
it's immutable we don't want anyone to
be able to modify this later so we we
set it up as a constant as final and we
want we actually want code later to be
able to get the value but if you ever
need to do an operation that belongs to
phone number say i want the area code or
i want the country code then that also
belongs in this class so so don't make
like wrappers around data and then put
logic that relates to that concept
elsewhere also add stuff like that
yep
yes this is this is definitely a part of
the main driven design uh so this is not
not specific but the point of this is we
should use this more in as a part of
getting better security so this is a
part of we call it value objects in the
main driven design
but
enforcing invariants is is something
that people tend to to forget or they
they write too little of these
validation
rules so uh we could we could go a bit
further with the phone number class so
in this this case we could go to kotlin
and we can can write it a bit in a bit
of a different fashion so
again we have a constant where we have
we store the value
and we have an init which is kind of the
constructor and we say that this value
must satisfy some checks
and then we have the checks where we can
so we can kind of simplify stuff and use
reuse stuff across so we have some
checks to say the length must be between
8 and 20 and it must match a certain
regex
and
the point of this is we have a list of
functions that we can call and then we
can reuse them
as in in other functions so we can
create a create method that returns what
we call an either
and then either is a union type if
or you might see it as a union type so
we and either either is either a
validation error or it's a phone number
and the point of this is we might not
want to throw exceptions we might want
to be able to return validation messages
so we can show them to the users without
kind of catching stuff and and maybe we
want to validate the larger objects and
get all the validation errors so now we
can do that we can try to to to
instantiate this object and we either
get a validation error or we get a phone
number back and then we can act on that
and we can also have the the function
that we had very is valid we just
checked that it returned a write so an
either has is an object that has either
a left or a right it doesn't have it
never has both a validation error and a
phone number it either has one of them
or the other
so
that's taking it one step further
next we can uh we can look at the
password primitive so the password
primitive we might want to ensure that
no one ever makes the mistake of doing
two string because that might happen if
we're doing like deserialization or just
a log statement or something like that
we never want to print the value and we
don't want to have a public variable in
this case because we want to make sure
that we only ask for the password for
this class
if we absolutely mean to so in this case
where we can create a aspiring function
just to have it we could even have a
counter there it says you can only
access this value a certain number of
times and then it will
throw an exception for instance so we
make sure that we we're not like
accidentally stealing this data
elsewhere
so that's also one way to avoid having
uh stuff printed we again we're using
these primitives to handle it so we
don't have to know when we're writing a
log statement like okay i need to make
sure that i don't print this thing and
this thing uh it's it's handled by the
class instead
so
some more examples email maybe we want
to check if the email is unique because
it's for user registration so we want to
check is does this user already exist
that's not something we can enforce in
the email object itself so we have to go
check somewhere
phone number you might want to check
that it's a mobile phone number and
that's quite hard and google has a
library called for this where that has
all the rules for all kinds of countries
where what's what's a mobile number
what's like a landline and what's
all other types of phone numbers that
you can have
but that's uh that's also something we
might have to check if we're going to
use this for two-factor sms which we
probably shouldn't but anyway
passwords
we can have rules that says it should
not contain the email or the phone
number of the user engine not contain
the names of the users and you can kind
of see where this is going it's hard for
the password object itself to know what
the user's names and email and phone
numbers are
so we can't necessarily enforce these in
the primitive itself
but that's why we have the entities so i
mentioned the the registration entity
earlier so here's the user registration
entity so the the uh
the primitives that we have up there
they enforce the stuff that they can do
but then the entity can wrap these
things and enforce rules across them
so it can check that we don't have the
phone number in the password etc
um
and uh we want to register this user
we're using this this user registration
instead of uh like separate fields
because we want them to be
valid all together as a concept
now
next up we we see this this this thing
here so we're going to store the exact
credentials because
those are going to be stored in a
specific way
and in this case we have a username
that's an email address and then we have
a validated password
so how do we get a validated password
what does it even mean
well a validated password could mean
that we we kind of go and look it up and
see that this is not one of the the
commonly breached passwords that are
spread across the internet in all kinds
of lists
and that's not something that the
password primitive can know itself
so in in this case we need kind of a
transformer where we can go from a
candidate password and to a validate
password and we can ask a service hey
can you validate this password can i use
this password and then it can do the the
the things i mentioned it can go and
look in one of these uh commonly
breached password lists and say no this
is not a good password or
you could say yes you can use this
password it's good and we can have the
other rules that we want there
so the the password primitive itself it
could enforce like simple syntax so the
password should be of a certain length
for instance but we do do need these
services to actually do uh some of the
work regardless
so next up um apis
we have again our simple application
here just even more simplified because
we've kind of merged the stuff on the
left into a client
and then we have some data in the
database
and we're going to read that data so the
client asks hey can i get some data and
we read it out of the database we
create an object on the server side and
we send it over to the client works
perfectly
then at some point we decided to add
this new field let's say this was a
credit rating or something that was
secret a token or a 2fa
secret for for the authenticator app and
we store this together with the user
data in this case
and but because we followed uh um
let's say we were using ruby on rails or
some other framework which kind of just
oh you have a model in your database
you're just going to send it right out
to the client and when we add this new
field we might accidentally end up also
sending the new field out to the clients
because we didn't do anything specific
to hide that field in the api
similarly we could have a way to store
data and normally in the web ui we only
send two fields
the two fields are sent in we read the
data from the database we overwrite the
two fields in question and then we store
the data back in the database
that works perfectly but what happens if
the user were to
specify
the third field
and send it in
well depending on how we wrote the
server side code in this case we might
have and we might end up overwriting the
data that we weren't supposed to
overwrite so suddenly we have some read
only data that the user could influence
this is called a mass assignment attack
and there have been many many uh
examples of this the most famous one
being edgar homakoff on github
igor hamakov he opened a github issue
that was a thousand and one years into
the future
because he was able to overwrite the
created timestamp of
this issue
and the reason why he did this was he he
was trying to tell the ruby and rails
community hey ribbon rails is doing
something stupid here like they're kind
of exposing everything and it doesn't do
any filtering by default so i can just
write whatever back and and then github
was vulnerable to this and he went as
far because no one listened to him so he
went as far as adding his own ssh key to
the ribbon rails github repo
and then he got got the attention he was
kicked out of of github for a while and
then they kind of realized that he was
only trying to do this to show that this
is an actual problem and by doing this
he influenced the design of the next
version of ruby on rails
where things were handled a bit
differently you had to tell
which which
properties that were allowed to be set
from the outside
but i think that's still kind of taking
a model that we have on the server side
and exposing it directly to the client
i don't like it because then if i want
to change something in my internal model
now i suddenly expose that to the
clients
so
we should of course have what we call
dtos
or contracts or even we could call it an
anti-corruption layer
we want to have a specific type of
object that represents the contrast the
contracts that we have with our clients
so data transfer objects con contracts
whatever they have many names
so in this case instead of exposing the
model directly we
copy stuff out just the fields that we
want so we leave the secret field
just on the server and we send it to the
client so the client will not see the
new field because it's not a part of the
model that we use for the communication
with the client
similarly with this malicious client
that's sending this extra extra field
down here
that extra field that doesn't exist in
the in the dto
in the contract so it's just going to be
either discarded or we just re reject
the request altogether but if we if we
decide to just discard any field we
don't know about well at least we'll
just copy the two fields that we like
and put them back in the database
again we just
we take like a really simple thing uh
it's a few lines of code to integrate
these contracts but people tend to think
it's it's too difficult i i have to
maintain all this stuff but i can assure
you it kind of gets harder if you don't
so uh let's say this is the wire format
that we have we have an order uh the
order has an id which is a
grid or a uid and we have some items and
each of the items also has an id and
then we have some quantities
so uh we're going to create a dto for it
so we have an order dto which has an id
and some items and we have an order line
dto
which has a product at the end of
quantity
and as you can see here we're mostly
using primitives because this is the dto
this is going to be json or xml or
whatever in the in the format that the
data is coming in as so in this case
we're using strings we're using ins
because that's the representation we
have
when we're going to json
but we're gonna
when the data comes in we want to
actually transform it into stuff that we
where we validate stuff and we can
actually put this in the dtos themselves
so we can create a two domain method
which will take this dto data and try to
create the proper objects for it
so in this case it will create an order
id with the string and so it becomes a
proper order id where it checks that
it's actually a uuid
and then it takes all the items that was
in the list and and creates proper
objects for them as well where we have a
quantity that enforces
the limits of what is a quantity is it 1
is it 500
and also a product that a and these two
can be different because we probably
want to separate order ids from product
ids we don't want to accidentally add an
order
as a product line
and this is actually a lot easier to do
than in at least in in in
a typed language because we can create
like a wrapped function and then just
use inheritance to get the two others so
it's like two lines of code to get them
separate but now we won't accidentally
in our code use a product id instead of
an order id or or
vice versa
which is really really nice
it it might seem like a very trivial
thing but actually when you're writing
code it's really nice because you get
compile time errors every time you try
to use the wrong thing
maybe you have like something that's
just an id and you don't know where it's
coming from now at least it has a type
and we can also say say that the order
dto is not only responsible for going
from the wire format into the domain but
it's also responsible for going in the
other direction
so the order dto or the dtos in in
in total they now have a responsibility
their responsibility is to know how to
map from
the wire format or the dto format and
into the
proper format that we want internally
so it's all hidden here
and so so the the our internal objects
the the proper order it doesn't have to
know anything about json or it doesn't
have to have these weird annotations
where json serializable or all kinds of
stuff like that it doesn't have to care
about that that's the job of the dto
then
we can also
because we talked about immutability
earlier like we have all these things
that are val which is a constant
maybe we also want if you're going to
add a new uh order line to an order
we want that to be immutable as well so
instead of just adding it to the list
the list could be a read-only list and
instead we create an ad function that
returns
either a new order with the new item
added or a validation order
a validation error and then we have some
checks that checks that well you can't
have more than a certain amount of items
in total on this order and that can be
enforced
uh by the order
uh
entity in this case
so now
we're kind of we
we we have this immutability which is
nice as well because we don't
accidentally change values across and
then suddenly there's something new in
the list and suddenly we have too many
items now it's not possible to create an
order that has too many items because it
does the validation before it's created
so
we now have
also a way to decide on what's the the
uh responsibility of a controller a
function or an endpoint function
what's what's it supposed to do well
it's supposed to map the request to the
domain objects and thereby validate them
because it tries to create the proper
objects
then it calls the correct processing
method
and then we map the results back to
http response in this case so now we
have
this is what every controller method
should do it should not do any logic
that's that's belongs to the processing
method so it could be like a service
class or whatever sits behind it
and then we're back to this thing
so now i talked a lot about input
validation how if you want to create an
object you have to check everything
it should enforce stuff and if you have
a valid instance of an object then
that's uh it's certainly valid because
we've done all the checks
but it's not the solution for sql
injection why is that
we could ask this guy
yeah i think he's dutch
and he tries to try to register
his name and that's his name it's a
valid name
and then he got a sequel injection error
or
a sequel error when you try to register
and there's something with clear text
passwords and stuff in there as well
which is
bad error message but still
if we wanted to apply input validation
well it's still his name
he should be allowed to have that name
right
so in this case input validation fails
us because well there's this attacking
character that he has in his name and it
kind of slides directly into most a lot
like bobby tables right
so
the problem with cross-site scripting in
sql injection is
data does not stay data
so we have some data coming in we're
going to put it as i mentioned in the
beginning we're going to put it into a
query language and then we kind of break
stuff
so data does not stay data this is a bug
right
data should stay data it should not
suddenly become control
it's a bug
but this is the problem with injections
is not that we necessarily allowed all
kinds of weird characters because as we
saw with the dutch guy
like
those those letters should be valid so
there have been some attempts and i did
this uh earl in my early career when i
started the code as well like i tried to
encode stuff when during input
validation so like i took the okay i
have the string it contains this uh the
single quote i'm going to encode it now
because now i'm getting it into my code
and i'm going to encode it immediately
so it never hits the sql injection
endpoint and php did this for a long
time by default so whenever there was a
single quote coming in it would add a
slash in front of it which was super
annoying when you tried to show that in
html and there was always a slash in
front of all the all the single quotes
so uh don't do it during input
validation because you don't know what
the format is you don't know where this
thing is going to end up it might end up
in a database today but like next week
maybe you you've swapped the database or
maybe you're going to send it out in the
json request
so don't do it there you should do it
when you're moving to the other format
so
we should use the languages we should
use the constructs would you use the
apis that we have to do this so for
instance with sql injection there is uh
parametrized queries they handle this
for us we don't have to care
good
it's just that we still tend to not use
them in a lot of places because sequel
injection is obviously still a problem
then we have process scripting now we
have uh frameworks like react and
angular and and svelta and all those
kinds of things they
most of the time they handle crosstalk
scripting for us they they tend to
escape stuff for us so we don't have to
care except if we're using like
dangerously set inner html and
friends of that
and then for other types we might have
to escape or encode
and now i have a confession to make
i failed to communicate once or i failed
many times but
i failed to communicate once i was doing
a
source code review
and
i found lots of sql injections with code
looking like this
so there's uh there's some string
concatenation happening here
uh this is not nice uh
so i so i was kind of finishing up my
report and i sent it over and said hey
it's not a good idea to do string
concatenation when you're building sql
statements
you should really use prepared
and so what i expected to happen was
something like this in this case like so
we have the question mark instead of the
parameter and then we say statement set
string to this id and then we execute
the query
but what i got back a few weeks later
was
this
so they just used prepare statement was
still doing the string concatenation
because i didn't say
stop doing string concatenation i said
only said stop doing prepared statements
and this is a fault of mine i
communicated badly and i think we
sometimes do this as security people as
well we kind of assume that everyone
else knows
you should do it in this way and then we
don't explain it well enough
but the question is can we do something
with the apis
and i think philippe dirk who was
talking yesterday he had some great
examples of this
we can wrap stuff we can wrap security
libraries we can wrap stuff in things
that helps us
uh convey the message and and makes it
easier for our fellow developers to do
things right
so uh the the example philip showed was
um
uh
a react mod
module called uh or a react component
called safe html which you was using
dangerously set in html but was also
using dom purify so that you could
display rich data without risking
cross-site scripting
but i'll also show you another example
trust the types this was mentioned in
the
the keynote by jim yesterday
what is trusted types
uh
in our uh in our browsers when we're
writing code one of the problems that we
have with client-side crossover
scripting is we sometimes assign
paint the data which is data coming from
a user which they are in control over to
inner html or outer html or we do
document write or we do all kinds of
other stuff or we use this dangerously
set inner html thing
as
shown down here in react so we're kind
of assigning painted data into the dom
which causes a cross-site scripting
so we trusted types
we kind of changed the api
so the way we do it is we set the header
which says enforce trusted types4 script
and now if we try to assign a string to
innerhtml
it says well you can't do that anymore
because you've enforced trusted types
so we we modified the api to say the
only thing that you can assign to an
html is something called trusted html so
you have to create a trusted html first
aha
how do i create a trusted html
well you create a trusted htm
html by creating a policy you use
trusted types to create a policy
and there you have a create html method
that takes the string data and then
converts it somehow
and then we can assign it after or use
that policy afterwards to assign to
innerhtml
uh uh we can actually skip the policy if
we want to because don't purify the guys
behind it are very clever so they
created a sanitized function that
returns a trusted type so if we have
trusted types and uh and first we can
just ask don't purify to say hey return
and trust the type once you've cleaned
this data and then things work as
perfect
another thing we could do and this is
something philip derek showed me
some some months ago is we can use a
default policy
so the default policy will trigger if
you try to assign a string to innerhtml
so instead of just blindly assigning the
string it's going to call the default
policy to clean it so now we can we can
use don't purify
and this would even work in libraries
right so we have a library and the
library is somewhere is doing a stupid
uh inner html assignment it would even
catch that
so if we if we just enforce truster type
and and and only have like a specific
policy that you have to remember to call
we might end up breaking some libraries
but in this case we we can even fix that
so um i've talked about
some code that was kind of kotlin-ish
and
it could also have been very similar in
c sharp uh or in java
but what about
typescript
a lot of developers these days are using
typescript well like we use it in
lambdas we use it on the client side in
a of course in a in compiled to
javascript way uh but what can we do
here like if we want to do the input
validation bit what can we do so uh
we now have classes oh let's use classes
so okay so we create a username class
and then we have a constructor that
takes some
value and it's a read-only
so it's very much similar to what we saw
earlier and then we do some checks
and then we do the same thing for
password and we create two
two instances one of the user name and
one of password and we try to call this
register function
so this uh this should work right
register username password that's great
the problem is
this also works so if we flip flip them
it's still going to work
because typescript
well not because typescript because
of duct typing
so
what
typescript actually sees here is not
username and password
it says
some type with a thing called value
that's a string and some other type
that's a value and it contains a string
and so that's that's why we can flip
them so we could even do something like
this and bypass the validation
altogether because yeah these this match
what we have up there like m two empty
strings that matches okay
crap um
what can we do about this then well one
thing we could do
which i don't recommend is we could add
private fields to all the method in this
case i'm adding a private field
it's uh called underscore i it could be
called
and anything
contains the value of one and we've
added it in both places so
why are they here
well in this case
typescript compiler will actually
complain we'll say hey
you have a password and you have a
username but they have different uh
declarations of this private property
so i don't like this and and it's going
to throw an exception but
this is
a bit ugly
in my opinion
so again we could of course go to the
entities and um
create an entity where we have proper
names for the fields and then use that
so at least there's only one place we
can go wrong and that's in the
constructor so we accidentally give the
two two values in
reverse to the constructor i think
that's probably a better option
but what about
input validation of json data
i see um
lots of places where people are kind of
just assuming that data coming from the
server is valid according to
what they expect in in the client side
code or vice versa end of server side
code we just assume that
the code that's coming in it has some
strings that has some
hints in the right places and we just
kind of do like an ass
to to
cast it uh and and it's not so nice
but i discovered this library called sod
and props to whoever colon is because
this is a great piece of code
so what we can do with saat is we can
create
contracts
so in this case i'm creating a
registration parser and in this case i'm
saying okay an email is a string it has
a minimum length of 10 and a maximum
size of 60 and it's going to match the
specific reg x and then i take the reg x
from
the uh
specs for
what you allow in a browser for an input
field of type email and use that so
that's one way to go
for a password in this case i'm just
going to check that it's a string and it
has a length between 8 and 256. so you
could easily add lots of more
uh
validation rules here and this is just a
simple example to show it and you could
also
combine these so you could take the
email like you say an email is this set
string stuff and then you use reuse that
across many
uh different of the parsers and the cool
thing about this is
we can also ask sod to create a type for
it
so in this case it won't be a fantastic
type with
proper classes and all kinds of stuff it
will still be primitives but at least
now we have a way to do proper input
validation and get out a type without
having to use json schema which is not
in tune with the classes that we have or
the objects that we expect the types
that we created now it's all coming from
this thing
and it becomes a type
and
the way we use it is we parse the json
data
with a parse function and it will throw
an error
if it's invalid it would also remove all
fields that it doesn't recognize by
default you can you can add a fall
through if you don't want that or you
could tell it to
to throw an error if there are extra
fields that you don't want
but this is one way of using it it also
has
a similar way of using it as the either
we can use safe parse
so with safe parse it's going to return
a union type and the union type is
either a success
or it's an error so in this case i'm
asking is this a success and no it's not
then i have parse result error which i
can use to if i want to show an error
message or if i want to login error
message or whatever
and then i can use parse result.data to
get the actual data
that's now been parsed and validated and
all that stuff
so um
no we can't get like the necessarily the
the proper type stuff that we had in the
the strongly typed languages because uh
it's duct type but at least we can get a
lot further using this approach than
just casting things
so i i really really like and recommend
this library
so um i've done this talk once before
and i'll always get the same questions
and i'm going to preempt some of your
questions
the main primitives seem fine and all
but have you ever used this on a real
project yes i have i worked on a project
for three years
and the only pieces of code i didn't
like was the ones that where we didn't
use this because it was very very nice
to have
the problems is often that where do we
put this input validation logic if we
don't have the primitives well okay so
we're going to have like a list of
regulators somewhere or some validation
function with some static functions that
does stuff
and we kind of tend to spread things
around and the validation rules they
don't have a home they kind of just okay
they're in the validation class which is
super long because it's used for all
kinds of validation where do we put it
now we have a home for it it belongs in
the primitives
so that's a nice thing
of course it can be an issue as well if
you want to use the same rules both on
the client side and on the server side
and you want to kind of expose them but
there are ways around that but yes i
have used this on a real project and yes
i really like it
it must take a lot of time to create all
those small classes
it's not free but security isn't free
and if you're not using the classes you
still should do validation so the the
discussion is more do you want to do
validation or not and if you want to do
validation then this is i think a good
way of doing it
if not you're going to have to spread it
around and
find ways of doing it that may or may
not work
of course you could use schemas of
course you could do it in other ways but
i like the fact that it belongs in a
specific place
what about equals and hash codes in in
those classes you created ah well
you got me there you have to implement
equals in ash code as well of course
because you have to check that the value
is the same
so i deliberately skipped it because i
didn't want to show
really long classes to to trick you all
now
but uh i yes you have to do that because
if you want to check if two usernames
are the same of course you have to write
the the equals method so it actually
checks that the the value is a match
what if we need to change the validation
rules ah this is the most difficult
question
what if you already have data in the
database
and then you need to change the
validation rules and then you have data
in the database that no longer matches
the new rules that you create
yeah this is annoying this is super
annoying this is also a problem you will
have regardless
of how you do it but you will the the
problem here is you'll trigger it when
you read data from the database and you
try to convert them into objects it will
fail there and that's a bit odd but at
least you you know that you have a
problem so um if you want to change the
rules uh one way of doing it is to have
a
script that you run before you go you
actually deploy the code so you you kind
of run a script
before you deploy a new version to check
all the fields okay i'm going to check
all the email address and check that
they match this new
validator that we created and see if
there are some errors and then you can
fix those so we had this problem we had
some phone numbers that where people
have been just writing garbage data and
we had to import some data from an old
system and so we had lots of bad data in
the database and we had this exact
problem and there are ways around it and
it's
annoying there and then but in the long
run having proper data is so much
better so uh
i'm going to try to summarize the things
that i think about this you might
disagree but i think
the first part input validation and
encoding or escaping stuff
both of them are needed it's defense in
depth we need to invalidate data as it
comes into the application and we also
need to encode or escape it as it's
leaving the application
i think domain driven security can help
us here i think it puts input validation
in the right place i think it can
enforce better data quality because we
have proper types going around and it
can stop and hamper many types of attack
because of the input validation stuff
and we can get things that used to be
runtime bugs to become compile time bugs
because we're going to catch them
because the types are wrong
and then we can have questions if there
are any
so i'm going to try to summarize for for
the people on stream so
one of the points was if you're using
just domain primitives then uh
you can't kind of reuse and you can't do
validation across
different primitives and as i mentioned
we have the entities so the entities can
do cross
field validation the other point was
when we're creating all these classes
we're using more memory
so it might make sense to instead of
validating each field
to have
to do the validation on the uh on the
aggregate route uh or like the entity
just just on the entity and then still
have strings and those those are valid
valid concerns if if
memory is an issue
in the systems that i have been working
on where we had lots of lots of
transactions going through it we didn't
really see the memory issue as a big
thing for us but of course that might be
a valid concern for for your code so so
the question was here um is there uh
like in in my examples i showed that we
had the the input validations rule into
the objects and is there a way to
specify them kind of outside the code
and
have them uh either compiled into or
stuff like that there probably is um i i
think that having them there makes a lot
of sense because they kind of belong to
that object i know where it's where it
is i know where i have to fix it if it's
there
but in there are cases as mentioned if
you want to have the same input
validation rules on the client and on
the server you might have to extract
them so you can kind of use them in both
places and and have them available both
to let's say java or typescript and
something like that so so this is not a
perfect solution but i just think it's
it's a lot better than
uh lots of other stuff i worked on and
seen so yeah
and i think that's it we're out of time
if you have any more questions please
feel free to come up and and heckle me
that's fine
thank you